[Music]
I'm Gordon Ramsey I love Britain's
favorite food
Indian but I'm no expert in cooking
[Music]
it so I'm off on a great escape visiting
India for the very first time on my own
culinary
Adventure each week we Brits eat three
and a half million curries but they're
nothing like the real
thing what are you trying to do kill me
I'm going to discover how Curry House
Classics should be made so I'm cooking
my way around India on a busman's
holiday that is delicious than I've been
in love with Indian food ever since I
grew up ever since I remember my mom
cooking her first Curry very good
[__] spicy it's not just me it's the
nation's favorite dish
I passionately believe that food is an
international language hello hello hello
hello and I'm going to use it as my
passport to explore India's gastronomic
Delights I'm escaping escaping because
the last 12 months have been pretty
shitty yeah here we
[Music]
[Applause]
go and more importantly get back to what
I'm good at
doing I want to
[Music]
cook tonight I'm beginning my Indian
Great Escape in the north home of the
Cora and the brani I want to find out
how the curries you enjoy at home should
be
made that's [__]
[Music]
delicious
[Applause]
[Music]
I've just arrived in India's capital
Delhi on the first leg of my Great
Escape morning how are you how you well
good to see
you oh my God it's so hard
Ain is that the air
[Music]
conditioning I want to discover the
truth about Curry I know our UK version
is nothing like the real thing so I want
to learn how Indian food should be
made 99% of the food in the UK regarding
the cures are all from North India Delhi
I don't know if what we're doing in the
UK is an insult to what they do over
here I'm not complete with the level of
Indian food that I know Delhi is the eth
largest Metropolis in the world with 17
million
residents my issue is are we doing it
wrong are we faking it and Delhi is
going to give me my
answer so my mission in Northern India
is a personal culinary Voyage of
Discovery all the classics such as Rogan
Josh burani and butter chicken come from
[Music]
here in the 19th century workers in the
British Raj acquired a taste for curry
creating a demand for it upon the return
to Britain and we've been in love with
Indian food ever since
India is a big mystery to me it's like
the Wacky Races
unbelievable I've never been to India
before and I have to say it's quite a
shock to the system I mean this is
extraordinary I mean kids everywhere
people are actually living on the
street I need a bit of guidance I'm on
my way to meet someone who can help at
one of India's most famous restaurants
the moti
Mahal it's here UK favorites such as
tandori chicken were
invented sea Chandra is an expert on the
food of Northern India and she's helping
me with my travel itinery hi hello how
are you very well good to see you see my
Chandra nice to see wel to India very
happy to be here she's one of India's
most respected food writers and
restaurant critics why have you brought
me here well the reason I got you here
is that this place Y is where most of
Indian food the way it's known the world
over they all began here I love M Mahone
the D chicken Tika M Mak as in butter
chicken the way chicken yes well butter
chicken started right here 60 years ago
seriously is there a difference between
what they're serving here to what we're
serving in the UK it is nothing close
what you're going to get here I mean I
was shocked that they even call it
Indian food in fact I have a problem
with it it's not Indian they put cream
and they put sugar into everything and
they think okay that's it that's done
it's not Indian food shall we order so
we'd like butter chicken of course
butter chicken tanduri chicken so you're
more convinced that I'm going to taste a
big difference to what I'm about
toat without without a doubt thank you
okay yeah thank you are you going to eat
with your with a knife and fork will you
tell me can't get the flavor of Indian
food with a knife and fork no I should
try that back at home in my it's Blas
fish it's Blas fish what do you think
it's absolutely delicious and it's not
um it's not dry it's moist it's moist
yeah nice now that's the dish you've
been waiting for so the butter chicken
this is
it nothing H it is nothing gives me more
pleasure than seeing someone eat and
saying bloody
hell how does this compare with what
you've had I mean that already Hest you
seea it's chalk and cheese it's very
flavorsome no and there's no it doesn't
taste
taint T you it's not like it's been
laced with tomato puree not at all fresh
tomatoes I think a working holiday will
show me the real
India I need to go native if I'm truly
to discover how our UK favorites should
be
cooked I'm not here to watch I want to
cook that's it I want to cook okay now
the thing is not stay away from the
touristy traps quite the contrary go
into the remote areas going to people's
homes going to the desert the best food
is in these little little areas it's not
in fancy places no go for the humble go
for the humble get to know what does
this do why is this yellow why is this
brown why is this little thing looking
like moss I think it's really important
for Gordon to understand what we Indians
eat every day our regular sort of
[Music]
food I'm off the luck now which is Fame
for its corers branis Babs and N
bread up to 13 million people use the
trains every day traveling the
subcontinent's 1 and a/4 million square
miles on Long Haul
[Music]
Journeys the express will take me part
of the 500 km to luck now it takes 12
hours to reach India's foremost city of
Cuisine and culture next India proves no
strolling the park I'm working under a
strict old Master to discover how people
really eat on the
[Music]
subcontinent right who's pissed him off
who's going to let ripet me in a
[Music]
minute I've come to Northern India to
discover the real versions of our
favorite curries in the UK I've already
had a taste of the real thing it's
absolutely
[Music]
delicious
right I'm in luck now it's crazy here
now se's got me a gig at this amazing
wedding taking place tonight for 1100
people but the chef who's doing the food
is supposed to be the dogs bollocks of
the region so this is going to be
amazing luck now is famous for inventing
the dishes we've all fallen in love with
our coras and
Banis my task is to learn how to cook an
authentic Indian burani the burani is a
classic party dish loved by the city's
royal family the
nobs
the NOS had their own Master Chefs
boates who developed a cuisine as
complex as anything in our Western fine
dining there are over a thousand guests
at this wedding wow small by Indian
standards I'm being apprenticed under a
chef famous for his intricate dishes and
Infamous for his lack of patience sounds
like my kind of
man that's the
kitchen
[Music]
Hi how are you how are good to see are
you well very well very well good
excited to be here yeah were just
expecting you oh well I got here early
yeah how are you fine good to see you
okay excellent head chef MTZ kesi was
born into the dynasty of bachis his five
Sons including fan my translator are all
chefs too I'm 79 years old he's 79 today
I me he's got handshake like a 25y old
in England they call you King
[Laughter]
K yes yes yes in England this man's
reputation is called the dogs bollocks
yeah the dogs nuts the number one okay
definitely going to explain him how old
is your father my father is around 84 84
it's gone up in the last 5 minutes
that's amazing so what's the first this
we're going to do for today the first
we'll do the the marination of Dumba
buyani okay in the UK the buyani is
often a land dish stodgy rice with
frozen veg and a tasteless
sauce but it's soon clear the complex
Dumber burani is going to be nothing
like the D UK version I would really
enjoy if I could do it never that's what
I'm trying to tell him like you just
give it to him he's like me a control
freak this is video yes I've never seen
two whole goats in a bani before first
I'm tenderizing them with vinegar okay
then they'll be stuffed with chickens
quails and eggs and served on a better
of fragrant rice okay okay yeah okay out
out oh Jesus thank you okay brilliant
now we're coating the goats in ginger
and chili you just
five okay T like that mtrs makes it
clear that great Indian cookery is
instinctive there's no recipe as
such you know what is trying to say is
whenever the new student comes and he
try to learn so you should respect the
the teacher there you know I definitely
respect the teacher trust me he looks
like a kind of guy I don't want to fall
out with
okay in terms of technique this dish is
as complex as anything in Michelin sty
cookery I'm now marinating the chicken
and the quailes in the chili ginger
garlic and yogurt
mix what is a basic takeaway in Britain
is a finely tuned feasting dish in
India back in the UK every Curry House
99% of them use the same same base for
the source here it's completely
different individual Curry individual
Source there's no same base it's all
becoming so much
clearer enough yeah I think it's
perfectly
okay what's the largest wedding your
father's ever cooked for
[Music]
maxim uh he's saying almost 50,000 to
one lakh people I done 50,000 oh my God
whole
shamana people from all over the world
from president to and minister
to he's SC to everyone Mt has got a
bigger head than me but I would love to
have the chance to work for him yeah
when he was a rockwe under the age of
35 yeah look at the hands they're like
shovels
look oh my God amazing amazing amazing
amazing 84 strong as an arst father was
almost 135 years old his father was 135
years old yeah
Jesus seriously I'm I'm not I'm not I
have seen I me from my childhood your
father was 135 Years brother
100 we been too much opium on the
fire the one thing inar isn't
bullshitting about is the
food the hard boiled eggs are coated in
saffron egg inside the
quail I haven't had a masterclass like
this since my Comm Chef days in Paris
that way Jesus the eggs go inside the
quail the quail inside the chicken and
finally we stuff it all in the
goat it's almost like sort of rewinding
give him birth yeah you're putting it
back in once he's been
born we're going to stitch it
wow it was a dish that was put together
for
right this this dish was made for only
for a
king not don't light him down just make
him stand oh stand them
up very
good this sh beats a supermarket Curry
ready
meal the goats have been left to cook
for 3
hours old boy MZ he's a he's a legend no
one knows his age but he's hard ass
trust me you don't want to mess with him
more importantly he doesn't speak a word
of English but we're communicating
through the food taste understanding but
what a technical genius way of putting
together a goat
briani the final stage is the rice for
the brani first we clean and part ball
basmati rice so the rice is cook with a
a bag of sort of aromatic spices so it's
like a Boke
[Music]
gani now I'm learning the technique
known as dumb cooking the rice is placed
in a special pan and saffron is added
then the pan is sealed with pastry and
the rice is left to
steam but one small mistake can mean
disaster rning I know
saffron time to put on the pastry seal
but it's not happening quick enough for
MTS what's wrong okay right who's pissed
him off was
that don't know no no don't don't don't
we're all going to get it in a
minute he's going to let rip at me in a
minute in situations like this you keep
your mouth shut and finish the job
quickly the whole style behind dumbbell
cooking is keeping all the flavors
locked in so sealing with the paste on
the outside is that little sort of work
of magic so how long for that now I
think it going take uh 25
we've been cooking all day and the first
guests are starting to arrive time to
assemble a dumber
[Music]
briani go back
yeah you going to pick this
[Music]
yeah look at
that the bani is finished with spicy
Indian meatballs called Kofa coriander
and dried
apricot amazing ask him for the first
time this morning is he happy with
it he says I'm always happy with this
good excellent at the beginning I felt
like a bit of a spare prick at a wedding
10 minutes into it he made me feel like
a chef thank you
that's [__] delicious refined wine if
he was living in Britain for the last 84
years would have a completely different
take on Indian food you know thatway I
swear to God it's delicious authentic
and
[Music]
amazing hello
nice this may look unusual to us but
mtas has his own ideas about
presentation I'm so Fired Up by what
I've learned and cooked with one of
India's top chefs the Dish's names are
familiar but the food is totally new to
[Music]
me let's go goat
briani next next please
I've noticed India is a country of
Foodies they're very choosy about what
they eat and this burani is disappearing
fast G you know you got to see the
layers oh yes
okay it's so popular we fought to save a
portion for the
[Music]
bride unbelievable what a day and what a
setup I knew it was going to be good but
I didn't think it was going to be that
good it's food from the heart soul and
passion and historic and it's given me a
lot of inspiration because that was
[Music]
amazing I'm now going on an adventure
into the wild to find a delicious but
little known
[Music]
delicacy I'm flying 1,100 km from Lo now
down to the state of chattis gar to
visit the remote tribal area of
bastar I'm going to discover the
unexplored cuisine of the the Rua tribe
they may be cut off from the outside
world but they are renowned for the
sophisticated cooking and amazing
Chutney we're going to visit a sort of
tribe in a forest almost like a jungle
like it's so remote it's it's in the
middle of
nowhere like most Britain I like to
start a curry with poppadoms and Chutney
but in India Chutney don't begin a meal
they used to spice up rice and and
lentil
dishes the darvas are famous for a
unique Chutney called Chapa which has a
secret
ingredient living with a tribe is
exciting but I'm more concerned right
now about arriving
[Music]
alive where's the
runway that was last time that was
[__]
TX oh my
[Music]
God now I've arranged a little
treat petrol on oh [__] has to go in the
neutral so it has to go neutral every
time this out of the way every
middle-aged man would love to get his
hands on this
beauty
[Music]
this Anglo Indian classic is a Royal
Enfield designed in the UK but built in
[Music]
India it's taken me on the trail of this
mysterious Chutney to the Tiny Village
of maip
pal there are 900,000 tribal people in
Basta my guide is rajish a former Dubai
businessman who now lives with the darua
tribe hi R how are you good to see you
well very well thank you so happy to be
here thank you so much how are you my
amazing what an amazing place look at it
unbelievable hello the derua speak a
language called gandi their welcom in
ritual for visitors involves Downing a
stiff drink made from fermented fruit
called malwa how you that Yes actually
this is our traditional drink so first
you say all the people
jarar and after you put one drop in the
art we Wast it yeah oh it smells
strong so not
good it's strong yeah strong very strong
because tribal people are very strong
people yeah I'm sure tribal people are
very strong but that is ridiculous
no you good to see you guys
[Music]
holy crap that is extraordinary
everybody seems so chilled here it's
like having cocktails in the
afternoon laid back relaxed
D cheers you are Jesus Christ for a
minute I thought she was dead mhm now
this is what I've traveled into the
world for the Chucky of the
ders taste
it
how
it wow
spicy Jesus Christ it's hot hot yeah but
it is absolutely delicious I mean really
Del fresh I'm never going to touch mango
chutney for the rest of my life but uh
this is not a fruit how do you make that
if you like come with me in the jungle
I'll show you what is this thing okay m
there's a secret get into the jungle
yeah yeah how far in it's a uh not sure
actually sometime 2 kilm far sometime
half kilm
far what is it inside that Chutney that
makes it so bloody
[Music]
delicious it seems the mystery
ingredient is at the top of this 80ft
tree
watching he's making a step have you
heard of a lad ladder no no no no what
one thing is there show you a little
later so there a surprise too what about
a safety rope no safety
[Music]
rope he's cutting down a branch with
what looks like a nest on
it watch out oh Jesus Christ so this is
the thing Garden that's it yeah oh my
God you so the Chutney is made out of
ants and they bite they're
everywhere
[__]
sh red Jesus Christ almighty aren't they
poisonous no not poison [__] when they
bite they bite how does that make a
Chutney ants um and eggs ants egg so
we're using the eggs yeah eggs and ant
both so it's like an ant caviar yeah so
they the they're the eggs
this is eg look at this oh come
on tasty
right tell me how tast it's it's sour
yeah sour sour sour taste yeah like
Tamarind yeah like Tamarind but it's
there's a little bit of sweetness there
as well when you burst the eggs inside
this is why I've come to India any good
Chef loves fresh
ingredients for such a tasty dish the
Chutney is easy to make red chili salt
and ginger are ground up with some ants
and their eggs it's rich in protein in a
place where meat is hard to come by so
you use 50% eggs and 50% ants
yeah
wow that's what you call a
Chutney yeah better than that goodbye
mango r jish and his friend hero have a
dish to go with the Chutney it's a sort
of chicken hot pot first the chicken is
mixed with a paste made from chili
garlic and ginger then it's put into the
basket made from woven leaves from the
Sal
tree a little bit water so it helps Su
steam the chicken steam what Ste so now
we are stitching
unbelievable it's like she's covering
the chicken with past tree yeah but it's
not it's a leaf this is a totally
different so that goes inside the fire
oh yeah okay wait a
minute little too
far you can't turn down the heat or turn
up the heat yeah oh
[__] are you sure that's going to be
[Music]
cooked ah oven
loves tell me two
thing delicious okay you know really
good thank you so much go thank you so
much well done hero staying with the
darua tri has been a real eye opener
incredible they have nothing yet they've
developed these ingenious techniques on
how to cook delicious food
quite touching amazing
[Music]
stuff wait first
time amazing take care and thank you
been
amazing take care real Indian food is a
delicious
Revelation I've fallen in love with a
dazzling range of fresh ingredients and
meticulous Tech techniques all far more
tantalizing than the curries we eat back
at
home from Basta my next destination is
JP in the desert state of
Rajasthan I'm off to cook with the
prince but first a grueling train
journey we
have um it's 10 11 at night and I'm
stuck on this train now for the next 12
hours last time I was in a bunk bed is
when I was living in a counselor state
in strapped one over with my little
brother and I was on the top and he was
on the bottom and he used to put his
feet underneath my bunk bed like that
lift the [__] up and then move me out
to the side and then swing me and I was
screaming like a baby to get back you
could hear Mom and Dad running upstairs
you know what's going on the bang and
the bang and the bang what's going on
the noise and then he would just like
Clump me back down and then quickly
switch out the light pretend to me to
[Music]
sleep I'm traveling to the desert state
of Rajan on the final leg of my Northern
Indian culinary
Odyssey after cooking with some of
India's poorest people I'm now off to
learn a desert recipe with some of its
richest all I have to worry about is
getting to jodpur on
time unfortunately this Train's got
other ideas it's broken down in the
middle of
nowhere problem with the batteries I
think
it's it's short circuiting everything
else so they've stuck a brick in the
middle of it to a earth it and B
separate the components but that will
hold for about 15 seconds till it goes
over the next bump then the brick will
fall off everybody okay good now ready
to go Choo
Cheo it's hard to believe yesterday in
the middle of a jungle and now literally
24 hours later in a desert yet I'm still
in Northern India which is which is
incredible
[__]
[Music]
[__] Steamers has got me an invite to
cook with a real Raj Prince nicknam Bozo
he's an expert on desert Cuisine and
champions Rish Shan's
Traditions hello boo Hi how are you
welcome what an amazing Place welcome to
R thank you so much we're going to head
off to the desert okay and do a bit of
um cooking and all that and rest of them
are going to Jo us later okay look
forward to it we thank you please yeah
that was a journey in a half I'm the
only Hoy pooy Round Here bozos are Cut
Above his real name is parik [__] sing R
and he's a Maharaja of job PA's nephew
how old is this this is this is this has
been there since 1952 first second
that's fine there we
go we're traveling 55 km into the desert
to Boo's
Camp amazing it looks beautiful it
is amazing it's just door so raw so we
start I'm cooking for Bozo's desert
dinner party tonight and he's teaching
me a slow cooked meat dish called could
God gosh made with
goat very basic there's nothing much no
there's no finery in this the tamasha as
we call it in India so this is basically
tenderizing the goat it's just
tenderizing the goat this is something
you grew up with this is what yeah this
is this is pretty much the kind of stuff
where one sort of always grew up seeing
all the elders like the uncles and they
were my father and they were cookie when
we went out shooting initially now with
the
masalas the goat leg will be smothered
in a masala mix made with chili and
turmeric and now for one of the local
spices is very indigenous to Rajasthan
you won't probably get it anywhere else
it's something which we call over here
kri kri yeah and it's it's it's it's
it's a family of millon M and it's it
works as a tenderizer it also s of gives
it that little Tangy
flavor fresh catery comes from a small
brown melon and it's only found in
rajian mix the ghee mix the ghee wow
this helps to keep it juicy and doesn't
let you know things dry up too much take
it out now comes the surprising bit we
moisten sackcloth and muslin then lay
banana leaves on top which we'll use to
wrap up the
goat now what we need to do is get the
Indian bread indan bread the chapati the
chapati so it's almost like a a
Wellington like a go Wellington we have
a f of beef wellington okay a
traditional you know sort of 70s retro
dish wrapped in a pancake then pastry
okay it's lined with mushrooms so it
absorbs it absorbs yeah that that's what
it's uh that's the general idea it's a
whole mean itself yeah yeah yeah this
particular recipe was taught to me by
one of our old old family chefs he's
still around can't see very much but
he's he's probably one of the best uh
Cooks I've known now for the messy pot
right what you have to do is take the
Masala massage in massage it into the
meat and the rest of it to spread around
spre everywhere yep okay good so I can
see bozo is not a man that likes getting
his hands dirty he's used to have
servants
around so okay here we go take this
wow do you want me to hold that as I
come as you come around well I think
it'll hold itself now okay okay right
you can do that but I just all right
Chef sorry about no no no I was trying
to help you get me do the shitty bits
you're in there doing the Glamorous bits
cuz you want to wrap it up yeah right
then you can wrap that
up [__] see you next Tuesday Gordon
come back come back we need you we need
to do the ditch come back please please
Gordon please I'm coming back we can't
finish it without you thank God I wasn't
your Chef in your Palace 20 years ago I
swear to God your ice Krispies would
never be the same so I was trying to
hold that on there for you so can wrap
the
rest I think Bozo considers me good
below stairs
material any other little shitty bit you
want me to do Chef if you can p out
just just thank you than you thank you
go anything El okay nice and tight nice
and
tight now we wrapped it up we just need
a bit of water to just completely tie it
up and and this 300 years recipe is
ready to be
cooked okay where's the oven yeah
because the oven is going to be
something which you my dear friend are
going to dig oh come on come on hey
where you know I've made your spices
yeah I've wiped your nose I've peeled
your garlic I've chopped your onions
well you know you've got to get the
whole desert experience the here's your
SP oh come on that's the ground you got
dig up a bit we need about 3 ft deep
uh-huh 3 ft wide and 3 ft right long
this Square pit you're spoiled I am and
you know what better way to get someone
as great a chef as you to do this for us
you just need to bed your back a little
more I
suppose and you might need to come
around this way now
that's I'm imagining that this is a
certain person's face that bit Morey and
than we are
done last time I dug this deep was in
the second [__] of Britain
skes have you heard of skes no I haven't
yeah we used to Holiday there fishing
chips lunch and dinner so what what were
you digging for there I was playing sand
castles
oh that's what hell that's a sandast you
just been that's
perfect
now we're surrounding the WRA goat with
hot coals and burying it in
sand pit cooking was developed by the
desert Nomads who wanted to travel light
without cooking
[Music]
utensils like all is
perfect now it's going to be in there
for say about 2 hours we pull it out and
I hope for the best really I think I
deserve a beer I think I do too you
deserve [__] all oh God come on I taught
you
everything
okay Bozo's dinner guests aren't
slumming out here his servants have laid
on some home Comforts in the dunes there
you I feel like bloody captain
cavan that looks
fantastic what taste it's just a red mhm
we need to open it up a
bit nice all
right got the knife and
forks there we are please excuse my
fingers thank you which one is pleas Boo
that is
delicious what a wonderful way of
cooking
goat what's nice is
the you're getting all the spices
without being you know chili hot it's
wet
with the bread around the outside which
I didn't think would be tasty but the
bread absorbs the juices it takes the
juices in yeah and it's sort of
pregnated with the spices so there's one
thing I've learned tonight since being
in the desert is sticking to
tradition tradition the tradition well
[Music]
done
After Eight Days on the Road
investigating how our favorite Cur
should be made I'm happy to be back in
Delhi I've had a whirlwind Cy
Odyssey and I can't wait to tell
[Music]
SEMA h no hi s it's Gordon hi Gordon how
are you I'm very well indeed thank you
my darling how are you very well have
you survived um I've done more than
survived listen I've had the most
amazing time I mean not only does it
open my eyes up but I mean it's just
it's blown me away I'm so happy and
thank you cuz the tips were
extraordinary oh wonderful I'm so so
glad um I'd like to say thank you and
use this opportunity to come and cook
something special on the back of what
I've learned over the week wow oh God I
can't get you I'm truly flattered my
dear yes if you wouldn't mind I wouldn't
mind getting a few of my friends along
would that be okay yeah no no nice a few
of your friends tell me tell me how many
people could get a chance to take G cook
for me most of my friends are real
hardcore J do me a favor don't let me
down I won't let you down I can't wait
to see what you think okay thank thank
you my darling thank you take care
byebye now bye bye bye bye I want to
prove that this Brit can make Indian
food using my travels as
inspiration and I've got just the place
to cook right back where I started at
the M Mahal the birthplace of many
modern Indian Classics such as a chicken
Tika I'll show you my kitchen
hygienically clean kitchen in India okay
great a very clean kitchen that means no
Stewart Littles yeah please you can see
with your own eyes hello guys does
anyone speak English in here do you
speak English no you speak English no
nobody speaks English who's going to
help me Mar nobody is going to help you
we don't have any Spar ship with us so
no help no help from
[Music]
here after traveling more than 2 and 1
half thousand km I'm back in
Delhi using all I've learned I'm cooking
a dish that does Justice to my culinary
Adventures but nobody's going to help
you right I'm really on my own and to
make matters worse seem is bring bring
in some influential food
critics seen some absolutely fantastic
stuff all week from the desert to the
Jungle to even on the
train so time to put that into practice
and
basically as it is in Ramsey's
world the knives are out first thing I'm
going to do get my chickens off the bone
take off the legs take off the breasts
get them into marinade at the same
time
get a chicken stock
going the dish I'm staking my reputation
on is slow cooked chicken with cinnamon
cardamon and
cloves I'm going do a really nice sort
of brown fragrance stock aromatic not
like any normal chicken stock you'd find
in the UK in with
that cinnamon this delicate chicken
stock will be the base of my
sauce
so no [__] water how' you get that no
wonder there's no [__] water look
it's pissing out there in the bottom
Jesus that's not normal
man if there's one thing I'm learning
the hard way it's don't cook an
important dish like this in a poorly
equipped kitchen where no one speaks
[Music]
English clim film clim film no do you
have any clim film no no okay don't
worry that's SI not like this but like a
[Music]
now I'm burn my [__] onions star
anise I need to e star uh star star star
star star in the sky star Ana fennel
Star St no don't [__] wave at me [__]
me star anise anise
no if I succeed tonight it'll be a
miracle at this
rate [__] me I'm in this [__] now dear
everyone stands and stairs and [__]
laughs but I'm in the [__]
now I'm going to marinade the chicken
now in the green
papaya this marinade is adapted from the
one I used for the goat brani at the
wedding chili We
Touch of clove powder cumin a little bit
of turmeric
a little bit of salt and a little bit of
sugar get that mixed
in you I'm I'm on the Fly you know it's
a collection of what we've seen where
we've been all week and more importantly
you know if it doesn't work I'm going to
look [__] stupid so it has to
work right
chicken the breast
in sorry
guys I found a pumpkin to make a puree
there's no conventional oven to bake it
in here so time to use the one Golden
Rule of Indian cookery think on your
feet
improvise like we did in the
jungle I
want to borrow your Tor EV
yeah thank
you
[__] [__] that's hot yep
[Music]
perfect right just about an hour to go
just starting the sauce now yeah for the
chicken it's based on that stock from
the chicken sweaty down the onions the
garlic the fresh tomatoes here then we
add the stock into that blend it and
then finish it with a touch of
cream Sea's decided to check up on me
she's invited a lot of influential
Indian Foodies tonight
hello howl today yeah well Jesus how's
it going it's been yeah it's been
amazing but tonight's the big night
right tonight is definitely do you need
any help I've got an apron in the car no
Jesus Christ but can I take a sneak peek
at what's your doing sneak peek um
pumpkin puree which was roasted in the
Tandoor oven with a little bit of cumin
okay so that was uh almost little bit
almost a pain in the ass there's no
ovens here yeah
possibilities possibilities oh Jesus CHR
and let me see there let me go around
and take a look there we thank
you happy that's promising promising
it's not finished yet I'll see you okay
lovely bye thanks ding just remember
today your day today my day [__]
me I've lost time cooking in this basic
kitchen and see as food food critic
guests have already
arrived so service just started
customers are walking in what I'm going
to do now these chicken breast just sa
them off that's the menu for tonight
folks no this one the new
dish so we've got four slow cook chicken
if we don't like this slow cooked
chicken can we give it
back see okay first
one from the jungle to the desert and a
huge Exquisite Wedding Banquet
my North Indian Expedition has all come
down to this my slow cooked chicken is
ready to go
[Music]
out I'm finishing the dish with saffron
flavored egg like those I use in the
goat
Perani go please go let's go go then
let's
[Music]
go
how's it
outstanding okay so's given his word he
says outstanding yeah I I really like it
it's it's different it's um it's
obviously really different to all the
dishes they've had here till now I love
the succulent of the chicken you know
it's not stringy it's not and it's and
it isn't a very heavy heavy kind of
gravy It's a Wonderful mix using Indian
spices but not overdoing
it's being made by someone
who is approaching Indian food or the
food of Mi or whatever with a clean
slate Gordon I've got to tell you you've
done brilliantly everybody's enjoyed it
and really liked it not only but
deceptively initially looked like butter
chicken but everybody took a bite and
said wow this is so light so lovely and
I loved your chicken I wiped the plate
clean yeah so I want you to now come out
okay let's just unil you to the public
to the public Jesus delhi's finest come
on come on come on to the Delhi Del yeah
come on come
come hello good evening ladies how are
we nice to see you to see you too come
Gordon I want you to meet everybody
right that's Gordon good evening ladies
gentlemen welcome how is the chicken
outstanding this has has a very distinct
light happy flavor before you ask me any
question that's the plate is there
anything left uh a bone which is a good
sign was delicious did you enjoy it
fabulous yes in fact I think they should
stick it on the menu I'd order it again
yeah if I came here again I'd definitely
order it again tell you something you've
passed I've passed you passed that's an
honor thank you so
much it's been an incredible week but
for me what I have discovered here is
that Indian food is far superior than
what we used to seeing at home so now
I've got the taste of it I want to go
off the beating track and maybe into the
[Applause]
unknown it's a warrior show it's a
warrior show from parents it's very kind
thank you very much hello hello
hello they all may look nice and smiley
but you won't want to [__] with them in
the jungle would you oh Jesus she going
to be sick get some water for the lady
quickly the Northeast is very special
and it's the opposite to what I
expected I knew you wouldn't take
50s so his throat with the chicken's
blood we smear all the guns it's okay
you come out alive don't worry I come
out alive yeah I'm still [__]
[Music]
myself I'm on my Great Escape my very
own culinary Adventure across
India
I've been in love with Indian food ever
since I grew up ever since I remember my
mom cooking her first Curry very good
[__] spicy it's not just me it's the
nation's favorite
dish I've already been to the north
where I discovered the origins of our
Curry House
Classics that's it yeah so the chuty
made out of ants they're
everywhere now I'm heading off on an
adventure into the Wilds of India it's
okay you come out alive don't worry I
come out alive yeah I'm still [__]
myself I want to uncover India's hidden
gastronomic
gems wow look at that black pudding who
would ever believe we're in India no
spice and try my discoveries out in
India's ultimate foodie City here we go
Mr
G
yo
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight I'm on the second leg of my
Indian Great Escape learning how to cook
my favorite food Curry and now I'm
heading off the Beaten Track to discover
India's best-kept culinary secrets in a
way I'm looking for sort of the unheard
of authentic Indian food and something
that's never been seen on any menu
Indian menu anywhere in the UK food and
dishes that we've we've never even read
about so for the next week I'm leaving
the tourist trail behind and going on
adventure into the far reaches of
Northeast India
bordered by China and Burma this region
is remote and
inaccessible but I'm told the mouth
watering curries will be worth
it they're made with ingredients
unavailable anywhere else in
[Applause]
India I'm heading out really out into
the Northeast tip of India almost out
into the wild
so yeah before I get there I'm stopping
off in Kolkata this is my gateway to the
Northeast and it will be the last bit of
civilization I see for a
[Music]
while this faded Beauty was once the
British colonial capital of India now
it's a hectic metropolis and all the
action happens out here on the
[Music]
streets one cup of tea please thank you
thank you very
much oh was
nice there are 135,000 stalls here and I
hear it's the best street food in
India what is it
potato very good in fact it's
delicious [__]
spicy I can't believe the variety on
offer egg sandwiches kata's very owned
come on Jay fascinating are they noodles
yeah noodles no noodles those chicken
noodles vegetable chili sauce with a bit
of tomato sauce on
there it's very good and everything is
prepared from scratch right here on the
street just the level of the basic food
on this street is of a delicious nature
and you've got like this Gourmet Trail
starting from the back like a little you
go canop with the eggs and then you go
down to the vegetable then all of a
sudden you hit the meat right at the
very end and then finish with the
dessert there's not a street like it
anywhere in the
world but right now I've got someone to
meet just around the corner in kolkata's
business district he typing it's typing
typing the court matter no email pardon
email no no no okay happy
typing hi Gordon I'm London how are you
yeah I spotted you long last welcome to
chaotic Tela thank you so much good to
see you season foodie nonon Bachi is one
of the few food writers to have ventured
into the impenetrable Northeast and he's
agreed to give me the lowdown on where
to
go what brings you here Gordon I'm
heading off into the Northeast and you
seem to be the only person that sort of
understands exactly what what what I can
gain from there well it will be a
completely different experience from any
other food available on the subcontinent
really yeah so not not like the north
not like Basta not at all at all nothing
to do with your uh chicken tikka culture
which is North Indian cormas Punjabi
food biryanis nothing of the sort
whatsoever
why it's mainly a tribal culture right
and people live off the Earth it's very
peasant food it's wild country there's a
lot of hunting going on for food except
for tables and chairs they eat anything
with four legs except tables and chairs
they'll eat anything with four legs
Jesus so be prepared oh
Christ it's a very exciting Cuisine you
better be ready for some hot food
because it's famous famous for chilies
oh really not known outside the
Northeast much so I can't find any of
the food from Northeast here on this
street no no no why not I think mainly
because it's so different and it's
unfamiliar to The Taste Buds right maybe
ha would be quite intriging to bring
back an influence from Northeast and to
put it on the streets here and believe
me it'll be the first time anybody has
done that kind of thing here
right I'd love to be the first person to
introduce the food of the Northeast to
this foodie
Mecca I will see you in a week's time
yeah fingers crossed
okay tomorrow I'll be traveling to
nagaland one of the most remote regions
in
India
I have a feeling home Comforts will be
thin on the ground and so tonight I'm
making the most of what Kolkata has to
offer oh
Jesus trust me when you get a chance to
take advantage of some luxury you lap it
up because only God knows where I'm
going to be sleeping tomorrow night the
next day I'm on a flight from Kolkata
traveling 900 km to debuger in Assam I'm
heading to
nagaland I'll be staying with a local
tribe that have a reputation for the
hunting progress and their fantastic
game cers I just hope the natives are
friendly as they'll be the first Western
Chef they've ever
met good to see
griton Gordon it's g r d o n g o r d o n
from debar I've now got 150 km road trip
to make through Assam before I even get
to the nagaland
Border 4 hours to go on like this look
Jeremy Clarkson eat your heart out look
no handed on the
telephone um I'll change gear if you
[Music]
want nagaland has a reputation for being
a dangerous place of westerners to
travel
alone slow down this looks like the
border crossing please stop nagaland
please check post
okay I'm being met by fagin she's the
only English speaker from the village
where I'm staying saying tell me you're
the friend of nonon yes how are my good
to see you what a journey okay welcome
to nand thank you very much indeed I
have a necklace for you to welcome to
nlin Jesus this is a skull necklace a
skull necklace yes yeah it looks like a
massive door knob so what what is that
we are head hunters from our tribe hold
on a minute uh you used to be or you are
we used to be head head hunters don't
worry no I'm not worry I'm [__]
myself if you're good then I want take
your head
Jesus if you're good I won't take your
head off sound like my
wife
[Music]
goodbye so have you ever traveled to any
part of the world like this like I have
never been to such remote areas of any
part of the world like this good
[Music]
ever it's okay you come out alive don't
worry I come out alive yeah I'm still
[__]
myself
problem with the brakes
[Music]
no motorways just don't exist here and
the endless bumpy roads are getting to
me surely we must be
near 2 hours 45 minutes after crossing
the border welcome to sh Village over
1,000 km after leaving Kolkata we're
finally here I really need a warm
welcome this is it blood as hell oh my
God welcome to my house thank you very
[Music]
much I'm on a culinary Adventure through
India and I've traveled into the Wilds
of the Northeast where I'm on the trail
of India's best kept culinary
[Music]
Secrets I've just arrived in nagaland
where I'll be staying with the conac
tribe and I'm the first Western Chef
they've ever met
um oh my
God hello this is my father Gordon sir
how are you your father's name what do I
what do I call
him Mr honay Mr honay yeah he looks like
a chief and this is my
mother how are
you she's fine nice to see you this a
warrior show a warrior show very kind
thank you very
much thank you very much that's amazing
who are all these people here these are
our relatives and villagers quick say
hello hello hello hello
[Applause]
hello what is that this all this is all
B yeah b b and what are these bits here
uh these are uh intestines intestine and
we eat them as well yes yes yes not now
I thought that was only hanbal elor at
that
the tribe might actually enjoy meat more
than I do Fan's father has even got a
version of one of my favorites on the
go so it's like a blood sausage like a
black pudding inside the
bamboo wow look at that black
pudding that is
delicious M that is very
good we don't put chili in our blood
sausage black pudding back in the
everything you think of any authentic
Indian food you never ever think about
black pudding but that's just you know
completely different thank you and a
great cup of tea as well [__] H this
is how we eat in Scotland you know black
pudding yeah and
tea he
said he said that because he's
good-looking and handsome like he has
got three wives
so Jesus what about you yeah
no yeah those laws don't apply in
wesworth the news of the world would
love that
one he said why don't you come with him
tomorrow for the
hunt I would love to go hunting he is
inviting you I thought it was banned no
no this is tribal land we are the owners
of our land and we have every right to
hunt to hunt and that's how the village
survives yes to think that 50 60 years
ago there was Tri
gangs Warfare revenge and the any way to
seek revenge was beheaded your
victim and that's that's that's not
[__] about now I mean that's pretty
uh so they all may look nice and smiley
and high fives and how you doing sit
down have some black pudding and a cup
of tea but you won want to [__] with
them in the jungle would
you
[Music]
after last night's welcoming ceremony
I'm Keen to get stuck
in this morning I'm watching the hunt
the trophies on show are Testament to
this Village's long history of living
off the
land Vin's grandfather is the most
experienced hunter in the village and I
would like an
introduction you read about these guys
and you hear about them at school in re
and things like that but [__] hell
You' never ever believe you have the
chance to sit and eat breakfast with
them right excellent good morning
sir good
morning how are
you now he's got five skulls on there
I've got four on mine what's the
difference only the the men that they
have taken the heads off wear this and
he's taking two heads off in his time
yes I better let him eat his breakfast
before he takes mine
off
[Laughter]
he's
laughing before the hunt starts I've
been asked to join some of the villagers
for a special
ceremony before uh before we go for a
hunt yes we will sacrifice
chicken his cut it through cut it
through his mouth with the chicken's
blood we smear all the guns or what
whatever type of weapon we taking for
the hunt we do this as a ritual just to
be one with nature like okay okay great
why is he just pull the intesting out we
will check whether our hand will be
successful or not if there's blood on
this side see inside then there will be
injury but there's no blood today so
there's no say it's a safe hunt yeah
it's safe
[Music]
[Applause]
hun the size may have been good but with
the entire Village ready for battle I'm
not taking any risks tell them all now
if you recognize a blue t-shirt don't
[__] shoot okay a wife and four kids
to feed are you a good
shot today they'll be tracking boar or
deer in the forest as it's going to be
turned into tonight's supper by F Jin's
father I've got a vested interest in
this hunt going
well so when we get into the forest
we're going to split into two groups and
circle around the hunt yeah we will
split into different groups Gordon just
be careful with the machine yeah so how
are we going to find the other Hunters
they are only waiting for the sound of
the hunting dogs and when they he then
they will also just run so we just sit
and waiting for the noises
he asked what do you do for a living
what do I do for a living in London I'm
a
cook he he's also a chef he's a chef as
well how much money do you earn in one
week for a cooking oh [__]
um that's a good question I mean from
from from from one 1,000 a week to to
£10,000 a week yeah
I'm is it go on he said my father will
come my father said he will come uh back
with you to London for
cooking maybe
tonight we can both cook together for
the
village said
ready thank you thank you yeah dinner's
on
me thankfully the hunt seems to be
hotting up which is save me from any
more embarrassing questions Jesus it's g
in
[Music]
Rambo [__] I missed with the [__]
machete [__] did you HT yourself I
missed with a [__] machete [__] it's
fine it's fine honestly absolutely fine
it's fine it's fine I know we're looking
for First Blood but it's not meant to be
mine yeah I was hacking back yeah and it
it sort of bounced back and I think it
was the corner yes yes that went in the
chicken said no injuries on the HT okay
good so they found something but not too
sure what it is Jesus Christ there's
guns going off everywhere
huh he's
happy Jesus it's a [__]
pigeon all that for that there's there's
more than that in there
surely that's not going to feed a hungry
Hunting
Party
[Music]
[__] but it isn't all over yet
[__] where's the deer the deer is's the
Deery this looks better so I got a deer
start a wild ball I started to [__]
myself they were celebrating over little
4 oz
pigeon
[Applause]
Wy oh
[Music]
oh the whole village turns out to
welcome its Brave Hunters these good old
boys know how to
party who gets the head the right thigh
and the head goes to the chief right
thigh yeah yeah who's that bit for the
guy who shot it
congratulations short well done great
shot aqu CH since you are our guest we
will give this chunk of meat I've got
that chunk thank you fascina they never
skin it first they just hack through it
and the head straight off I feel very
honored to be given half a saddle of
deer especially when I did Jack [__]
this morning to catch it except put an
ax through my [__] foot what a knob
right let's get
clean now for the real reason I'm here
here I'm going to see what makes a
nagaland curry so different to anything
I've ever tasted
before as I've been gifted the venison
Mr honley is going to create a curry
using the ball that he
slaughtered so in there kidney kidney
flesh kidney liver liver and belly and
you cooking everything at the same time
see normally we'd cook this separately
it's very rustic J mean nothing's
filleted nothing's ever off the boat
and what's that dad's putting there now
my father is uh putting another kind of
leaf which you find in the forest and
what's it like thank you it's quite
citrusy know yeah yeah it's like
lavender we use even the fruits for SP
like pepper everything Mr Holley is
using in his dish comes from his own
land this is the first Indian curry I've
seen made without any dried spices
what's that doing with the chilies he's
uh roasting it we have a better
flavoring if we roast it on the ash like
that yeah it gives a bit aent yeah well
we got we do the same with peppers and
the most surprising ingredient is
something I've never seen before it's
bamboo
choot yeah that's a fascinating smell
that you know that slightly spicy Edge
to
it while the pork and the bamboo Curry
Cooks I'm going to try out these
nagaland ingredients with my saddle of
venison to see what I can come up
with pure
fillet just a little touch they intrigue
me the flavor there you
[Music]
know how'd you turn up the
gas thank you how many westerners have
come and cook in this kitchen none no
I'm the
first
[Music]
H it's a tradition in Scotland we always
have a swig each oh yes it means our
passion is joined with the dish okay
while my L and Curry reduces Mr hunley's
pork and bamboo Curry is already done
and I can't wait to taste it the pork is
delicious very tasty the chili of the
garlic and it looked quite sort of
boring and greasy but flavor wise
delicious that's delicious the
pork the villagers from today's hunt
that didn't get a cut of the deer came
to share mine very
nice happy yes Jordan y can you just
give them a second help
There's real Community Spirit here and
it makes eating together all that more
enjoyable goodbye
sister if I don't see you in
this the pork dish I tasted of theirs
was amazing you'd think that there was
15 different spices the dried bamboo in
terms of flavor it's intense yeah has an
intriguing sort of um turnip stroke
cardamon sort of slightly spicy Edge to
it who would ever believe we're in India
no spice no turmeric you know no
coriander no cinnamon no clothes
everything's
just you know from the
ground it's quite interesting you dive
into their world and you get rid of that
monkey on your back and all of a
sudden you start to relax in a big way
and forget anything outside this
[Music]
Village I Came In Search of India's best
kept culinary secrets and nagaland
didn't disappoint I've had my first
taste of this Region's indigenous
ingredients and I can't wait to see what
other surprises the Northeast has in
store thank you very much take care
thank you made me feel so special best
wishes thank you m okay take care
upwards and
onwards and I've taken a bit of nagaland
with me I want to use the bamboo shoot
on my food store when I get back to
Kolkata extraordinary different and
Incredibly rustic very humble very
simple but fascinating food dough
totally um
unspoiled and in a
way nothing Indian I'm now heading back
into to the state of Asam on my way to
muli it's an island in the middle of the
brahmaputra river where fish is
plentyful and the locals make an amazing
fish
curry but first I'm stopping off in
jat there's an event going on today by
some crazy lady who's attempting to
stick over 60 chilies in her mouth
within 2 minutes and eat them and then
she wants to go on and rub more in her
eyes uh can we make this on the way to
muli we won't miss the ferry I've got to
see it yeah okay I mean is she nuts
unreal let's
go more chilies are eating in the
northeast of India than anywhere else in
the world and as Sam produces the
hottest on
Earth excuse
me m of one amandita Tami has a massive
appetite for
them today she's attempted to break her
own world record for eating 60 whole
chilies in 2
minutes taste pleas
yeah this is no ordinary chili and
Nandita will be munching on the boot
Jia yeah the whole the the whole thing
but don't eat it don't don't eat it
don't eat it just take he's taking time
to have a bite but not to eat it not to
chew it it will be very okay
hot this baby is 200 times hotter than a
jalapeno it's a chili nuclear
[Applause]
bombb that's very hot one is enough very
very hot indeed my mouth's still burning
on a little piece of one are you
mad no okay good luck so here we go I'm
playing safe by being
timekeeper ready 3 2 1
go 10 seconds gone oh my
God
one one minute G
[Applause]
minute [__] Excuse
Me 2 minutes dead stop oh Jesus she
going to be sick get some water for the
lady
quickly oh my God how many's left how
many left
19 is here so she 49 so she's 11 off the
Record unfortunately
491 you okay don't cry don't cry is she
okay don't get upset over a chili down
but not out and andita has decided to up
the
ante she's going to try to rub more than
12 chilies In Her Eyes in under one
minute how many is there 1 ready 3 2 1
go
[Music]
15 seconds gone come on you L wake
up 30 seconds
gone come
on 15 seconds to go you only got six
left five 4 3
2 1 and stop
excellent fantastic you
okay we started off with 30 24 she
broken the record she's broken the
record she's broken the
record the world record 24
[Applause]
Chiles excellent congratulations well
done really well done I think you are
mad excellent I mean those chilies were
extraordinary hot I mean unbelievably
hot just biting into one it just sort of
exploded and all of a sudden your mouth
went on fire but it's a very bizarre
thing to witness she's off a trolley a
confirmed
[Music]
nut I'm on a colonary adventure in the
northeast of India traveling through the
most remote parts of the country and
tracking down dishes that can't be found
anywhere
else I'm now leaving the asame city of
jorat to travel 20 km along the bruta
river to the Arid of
muli 2hour fairy ride to muli peace and
quiet now there's something quite
addictive to a fast pace fast life but
it's also nice just
to slow
down muli is the largest river island in
the world and for 5 months during the
monsoon it's almost almost entirely
underwater fresh water fish are
plentiful and so there's no better place
to find a delicious traditional fish
[Music]
curry I'm here to meet one of assam's
most celebrated chefs at laaka he runs
two restaurants and he's agreed to show
me one of his Classic Fish
curries how are you I'm fine good to see
you good to see you we start for pissing
fishing fishing oh fishing yes you like
fishing I love fishing yeah because
people of us we like
fishing let's hope ATL's cooking is
better than his English you ready yeah
ready you move wait for me yeah yeah yes
come come come come yeah but the brains
don't work on mine yeah yeah this is my
place that's why I was 150,000 Islanders
live here and they survive almost
entirely on a diet of fish and all of it
comes from these freshwater
ponds 99% The Village live on fish yes
yes fish fish
wow Jesus Christ that boat's not going
to put up with a fat bastard like me I
tell you bance you have to balance yeah
yeah yeah I'm trying yeah I'm
trying that's
great well that was a [__] start wasn't
it see I knew it wouldn't take
50s
sorry guys we apologize for me go you
were so heavy you're a lot lighter than
I am look how skinny these guys
are they're not even 60
kilo Jesus he's so
L these flimsy boats can't take a
culinary heavyweight like me so on to
plan
B well well we got some more fish from
the market we've bought some fish and
now at's going to cook Dena a
traditional asames fish C
that has a truly unique flavor and
what's that called is it is it the
elephant apple uhhuh and what do they
taste like apples it's cha choa yeah
it's good so they're acidic yeah it's
this tropical fruit that gives DGA its
signature sour flavor which will add
bite to the earthy Taste of a freshwater
fish so where's the recipe from everywh
some people use this type of fish
okay green chili very good but no spices
no no only chili they use uhhuh yeah why
is that our sili is so special y so noce
lities of sili chili you know that that
is a hottest C in the world yes so I ate
little child yes garlic what have you
got in there what have you put
in
excellent
[Music]
good and is that you done then yeah my
my good is finished Curry's finished
curry in a
hurry you like my traditional Asam food
the curry is delicious thank you and
you've managed to make it with no spices
yeah so I totally understand where
you're coming from it's been very good
thank you thank you thank you now just
before I go I want you to say one thing
for me fishing fishing snake
snake no it's not good snake
snake
on my trip I've realized that the curry
we know and love in the UK is really a
narrow selection of the amazing dishes
India has to
offer I've discovered new ingredients
with unusual flavors Like Elephant apple
and bamboo choot and tasted the hottest
chili in the
world the Northeast is very special and
it's sort of the opposite to what I
expected because you there's no G Masala
you know there's no there's no there's
no powders it's all fresh fragrant very
little spice fascinating food dough
totally um
unspoiled now I'm leaving the Wilderness
behind and traveling nearly 350 km to
goah
hatti this asame city is expanding fast
but the locals still hold tight to
tradition and one in particular is very
close to my own heart home cooking
number every year a competition is held
to find the best asamese dish in the
region and it's happening here to today
40 Cooks battle out for the
title I'm going to enter but in order to
rub shoulders with the best cooks in
Assam I need a winning recipe sove
wangled and in with a local Domestic
Goddess at all suggested that I spend
some time with these misses she's going
to show me exactly how she cooks if
there's one way of going back to Kolkata
with some really exciting stunning
dishes it's going to be from this
competition
yes hello rashman how are you I'm fine
I'm fine to see you good to see you
finally okay this is a first for me
entering a domestic competition actually
today I'm going to show you how to cook
chicken with sesame seed chicken with
sesame seed yes and who taught you this
dish yeah I I just learned it from my
mother from my granny I I always do my
cooking at home because at he doesn't
like to cook at home ah he's better in
his restaurant he's like me oh sure you
know why got the staff at home
oh get that nice and hot this is the
mustard oil oh yeah Christ that is does
smell nice
yeah we we never use refined oil what we
prefer is the mustard oil right and
that's the flavor yeah we prefer less
oil I feel like I'm back at school with
my home economic
teacher do I look like a teacher yeah do
I yeah young and sexy oh cool cool W so
onions garlic in chilies so you put them
in yeah yeah all the chicken in it's
quite dry but they don't use too much of
oil that's why very slim and beautiful
he's a lucky man as thank you I do lots
of yoga you know Yoga Yoga oh too boring
for me
yoga rash me's healthy family recipe
then uses fresh turmeric and coriander
the color has to remain green so it's a
green cry you can Jesus this is a
housewife competition you're so serious
and so strict it will remain green I
promise yeah that smells delicious mhm
color looks amazing
yes I don't recognize the final
ingredient it's black sesame seed paste
and it's only used in Northeast Indian
curries okay good it's very tempting
isn't it it is very tempting it is
delicious and it looks fantastic
yeah are you hungry uh I am a little bit
I don't like to eat before I go into
competitions you are very nervous so
nervous energy yes yes real point you
know since you are nervous you don't
want to eat I have a little
taste yeah very good everything is
perfect yeah everything I'm not going to
say D I'm going to say Chef thank you
thank you thank you you're most welcome
that is delicious fingers cross I think
atle's misses might actually be a better
cook than he is so this is a token of
love for me and just you're going to win
it it's a good luck okay 3 tbsp of
garlic ginger trying to past sesame seed
paste at the end at the
end hello Jesus the best dish in Assam
is a much sought after
[Music]
title yes I'm here to yeah I'm here to
cook I of this thank you very much
indeed
19 my 40 fellow competitors have been
perfecting the recipes for months but I
want to give them a run for their money
Ready Steady we start Ready Steady we
start I oh
[__] I'm feeling pretty confident I just
need to remember what goes in
[Music]
first do smell D no smell yeah not too
much garlic no okay good right lid on
keep an eye out for me please yeah and
just turn down the Gas a little bit and
have a little Wonder while that reduces
I'm sneaking off to spy on the
[Music]
competition and this one is pigeon
pigeon that smells nice though what's
this one here opium opium [__]
Opium poppy seeds puppy
seeds and this is chicken chicken oh I'm
doing chicken as well what else have you
got in there onions garlic onion garlic
and ginger so everyone's doing a little
bit of decoration aren't they is that
for your decoration wow okay right I
better get my ass in here and do some
decoration this lot might look like
Indians answer to the Wi but they're
actually pretty good Cooks they're now
garnishing their dishes it's gone up a
notch bloody how they started out as a
sort of domestic sort of you know local
competition they know what they're doing
crafty
buggers well Two Can Play That Game
hav't done one of these things I at
College a little Van Dyke of tomato 15
minutes left yes thank you thank you
Angley toand in please come out the same
color as
rashim
[__]
[__] got to stay green okay sesy paste
in 4 minutes you have to come to the
presentation table the countdown begins
y I've never been so much in this [__]
in all my life life you know that stop
please [__] [__] so all the participants
please go and take your seats the judges
will taste your food and give their
marks uh first Runners
up first Runners up Mr
Gardon run
up give oh [__] it's only number two not
okay well you got to be grateful
excellent thank thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
the
winner she is none other than tag number
14 elim go Swami woo go Swami
congratulations what was the dish
Chicken Chicken Again Sam what did she
do to the chicken that I didn't do
papaya and can papaya with chicken yeah
excellent give
you a Panasonic pressure the cooker
yooo yes I love you all thank you I
don't like coming second best okay next
year I'm coming back oh yes number one
thank you papaya and chicken that sounds
interesting that doesn't it yeah and I
mean okay I didn't win fine but what I
did come here for was to pick up some
knowledge to see how I can put that in
to the streets of Kolkata thank you
ladies thank you R need goodbye
[Music]
now
get me to the
airport
quickly one week ago I set off an
adventure into the Wilds of the
northeast of India to track down the
fabulous dishes that are unique to this
region the Northeast is very special and
it's sort of the opposite to what I
expected I've discovered that the food
is completely different to any of the
Indian Classics I've cooked before yeah
there's no G Masala you know there's no
there's no there's no powders it's all
fresh fragrance very little
spice now I've flown back to Kolkata
where I'm about to put my neck on the
line Northeastern curries have never
been sold on these streets
before I'm going to use everything I've
learned to create dishes that will show
this city what it's been
missing it's the crack of dawn and I'm
up early to join the other Street Cooks
already preparing for a busy
lunch DJ Now the streak starting to get
busy everyone's starting to sort of get
themselves organized and there's really
nice smell already so the heat is
[Music]
on with over 135,000 stalls my
competition is going to be tough my
Northeast cers need to be good enough to
Temp customers away from their tried and
tested
favorites they wouldn't have seen or
discovered food like this before so I
just hope in their hell that they don't
turn their noses up against it because
they don't recognize oh that's not sort
of what we're used
to and I've hired some local lads to
help me
out how are you sir good to see you sir
excellent and this is and is I IO tapan
and IO zagu zag Zagat are you sure
they're not bunking off school no no
definitely he's not I didn't him okay
right okay first thing yeah I need um
the fire lighting
yeah I'm going to draw on the unique
flavors of the Northeast to create three
delicious curries my first is chicken
and green papaya inspired by the winning
recipe at the cooking
competition it will have that classic
asame sour Tang that the locals won't be
used
to Green papay helps it not just soften
the chicken but marinade it also gives
that really nice tart
flavor I'm going to make a fish curry
using the dried bamboo sh from
nagaland it's something of an acquired
taste and I don't know how it will go
down
here it's a combination of a sort of bay
leaf stroke lemongrass with a little
hint of licorice first time for you I'm
so
pleased my final dish is a Northeastern
take on vegetable curry instead of using
dried spices I'm using fresh ones making
it a more subtle flavor finish with a
puree of sesame seed almost thicken the
vegetable curry with the sesame seed
paste and then after that the fresh
coriander paste just one last thing to
do before I open my stall I am sweating
like a pig I look like a pig I stink
like a pig right I'm going get
changed right cooler much better so it's
not exactly Chef whites is it but I
suppose it's uh it's equivalent a local
Chef white to tell you what it's a lot
cooler huh nothing wrong with going
commando in the midday
Sun time to see if my take on the
northeast curries can win over kolkata's
Foodies hey
you must stress that it's from the
Northeast you must tell them that tell
me how I
say here we go who's first chicken one
good first one good thank you chicken
coming now let's fish carry certainly
actually this is a new thing to us in
Kata I don't know other people will like
it or not but in my opinion it's really
a super one let's go let's go let's
go the food is very good and uh the the
I had the face with bamboo shs it's very
tasty
bamboo cooked with green papaya thank
you let's go chicken Papaya's gone down
a storm extraordinary it was really good
I never tasted a bamboo dis
and the vegetables and these are really
good last chicken last FL last that is
unbelievable that's barely well 50
minutes and over 100 portions of
chicken's gone which is fantastic news
with the last of the chicken papa gone
my fish and vegetable curries quickly
sell out
too so thank you that is now officially
Gordon Ramsey's Kolkata Cafe closed
finished it's been a great day day I've
enjoyed myself and judging by the
reaction my Courier has been a
success 500 600 700 800 900 1,000 2,000
so
2,750 yooo that my son is a good
morning's work okay yes thanks every
people say the food is excellent did
they yeah definitely everybody said
that but there's one person's opinion
that really matters food wrer not nonon
arrived to give me his
verdict hi Gordon how are you doing well
than how are you I'm good how was your
week uh my week has been amazing so what
did you cook up today so today we did a
um a take on a chicken with green papaya
we did an amazing uh fish curry I saved
you a little portion cuz I was getting
slightly
[Music]
worried no wonder you sold
out thank you believe me you happy with
that not only that you have actually
succeeded in doing something many people
would have said is impossible well done
it's very
kind very well done very well
done I look ridiculous and I must have
lost half my body weight in sweat but
I've proved that curries of the
northeast of India are worth shouting
about I I thought my first week in India
was a eye
opener this one was a shock I think cuz
it's hard to believe that exists it's
almost like you weren't in India the
culture is equally as exciting as the
food just an amazing eye opener the
Simplicity the concentration of the
great ingredients and not pissing around
with
it India's helped me to become you know
not just you know a proper Chef I've
never I was never out that bracket but
it it's helped me to confirm what I love
doing more than
anything can we top that I doubt it but
I can't [__] wait to
try what are you trying to do kill
me my God that's a proper Guru first
time I've ever gone two days without any
form of meat or fish yeah here we
go dangerous [__] mad
mad tonight I'm on the final leg of my
Great Escape my very own culinary
Adventure across India I'm learning how
to cook my favorite food
[Music]
[Applause]
Curry
[Music]
this is the third and final leg of my
culinary
Journey I've done the cities done the
mountains the jungle and now I'm off to
Mumbai it's going to be my gateway to
Southern
India with 14 million people Mumbai is
India's Financial Hub and home to
Bollywood and then from there down south
to some of the most stunning coastal
line anywhere in the world Fame for its
fish it's home of the spices is where
the spices originated
from I'm completing my culinary
adventure of India in the South it's
famous for its fish curries and unique
spices India produces over half the
world's Supply but I'm uneasy because
South India is also a hot bed of
vegetarianism two fifths of Indians are
vegetarians and half regularly eat a
veggie
diet personally I'm a rampant carnivore
and vegetarian holy than thou attitudes
wind me
up C my dress
please welcome to Mumbai thank you very
much already within the first 2 minutes
just seemed
crazy I mean everyone's a th000
[Music]
mph look at that most amazing Indian
wedding
beautiful absolutely
starving I'm meant to be rending with a
culinary
expert right cap Madras Ras no chicken
anywhere I'm meeting Rashmi UD
sing she's India's top food critic and
wrote the country's very first
restaurant
guide R me hey how are you my darling
great to see you nice to see you thank
you lovely to see you you look wonderful
thank you you and you look really
wonderful but you look a little hungry
yeah you know I'm very hungry all I want
is butter chicken this is a pure
vegetarian restaurant the district is
pure vegetarian even if you want to run
an apartment Garden you can't if you're
a nonvegetarian serious so out I know
there's a lot of veggies in India but a
whole town they're convinced
vegetarianism can combat the evils of
Modern
Life what is it with meat eaters why are
you so anti eating so much of chunks of
meat and faga and all that we believe
that that is what is responsible for
your bad temper eating meat makes you
bad temper what a load of bollocks
unlike all that stuff you eat this is
actually good for your spirit your
emotions your feelings it will give you
calm it will relax you meat doesn't make
me angry it makes me excited just calm
down let's get you something to eat
please then we'll talk about our South
Indian Mission yeah let's Okay Che okay
repeat after me promise promise to try
to try the vegetarian food seriously I I
promise I will taste try vegetarian food
with an open mind with an open mind to
show me what's out there rashmi's
ordered me the most popular veggie meal
in India idly sber and roll do of
pancake what's that a lampshade is that
beautiful where's the light bulb we buy
things like that at the flea market in
London you have a clothed what is that
M first I'm eating the ity in a spicy
sber
soup the texture is like um like a sort
of warm sort of textes like a warm scone
it's nice yeah I like that it's moish
it's lovely okay L nice you have an open
mind and you enjoyed it definitely
against my better judgment I've asked
rashmi's advice on where to find great
vegetarian food she has a radical
suggestion you are going to visit an
ashro a what an
asham a spiritual Retreat you're going
to go and live there with mons there's a
lot of fabulous vegetarian food there
I'm not spending a week and my last sort
of exciting week as a vegetarian no
chance I'm going now the whole week we
going to go back with a journey not just
to India but into yourself I am not
[__] Amy win House's husband I'm not
checking into rehab you're not taking
rehab you're going to find yourself you
are in our country you are our guest you
are like God the God in Me salutes the
god in you have a great time good Lord
be with you the Lord Jesus and call me
if you need me uh yes absolutely
defin Jesus
[Music]
taxi it's an unavoidable fact India is
the largest country of vegetarian in the
world and Southern India is famous for
its Vegetarian
Cuisine so I'm traveling 1300 km from
Mumbai to the town of coin bat I really
must have lost it I'm going meat free
for the first time
ever now this part of the journey for me
is going to be one of the most
fascinating because we're in tamalu and
rash me's arranged me to go to this
amazing ashram so it's a temple but the
bad news is it's a temple for
vegetarians the thought of spending life
without eating protein meat AB Angus
stay
tartar hello to get me there I'm hiring
a car
hello this moris Miner was built in
India by Hindustan Motors a nickname the
baby
Hindustan my God you could never hump in
one of these could you H and the seat
doesn't go back now I don't no obviously
not no horn obviously
fantastic
I'll take good care of your baby
certainly thank you straight the first
okay great
[Music]
Beautiful Jesus and a smooth
transitional gearbox [__] me where the
[__] is
third asham this way yeah thank you I
think the fascinating thing that strikes
me about this Temple is that it's it's a
very popular place nobody eats meat Find
Your Inner Strength make you more happy
less angry less frustrated less
stressful hello is this where the
veggies hang out I'm looking for the
guru
ashram I'm getting clean for the first
time in 42
years oh [__] see even the gearbox won't
agree with me now cuz it it can hear
that
oh I'm not going to be eating meat for a
couple of
days there he is my God that's a proper
Guru my guru's name is sad Guru and he's
a lot racier than your average
[Music]
Yogi I've heard his cooking is the best
in the state it's not the kind of
Transport expected you to use to get
round no uh people always have this idea
being holy means being impracticable yes
yeah Drive wife kids I have a wife and 1
million
children saguru asham is the Aisha
Center it gets over 700,000 visitors a
year he's a popular Maharishi and he's
looking a bit more serious now I'm very
excited to be here more nervous than
excited I'm never gone two days of my
life without eating meat your system is
essentially designed to handle
vegetarian diet right if you eat
according to that it it handles food
effortlessly yes every human experience
has a chemical basis in the system right
so if you want to create the right kind
of chemistry there are various things
that one can do yes one of the things is
food if you create a chemistry of
blissfulness that's how you are all the
time that's
impossible I'm not going to argue in
your temple that's for sure I'm dying to
see the kitchens let's go thank
you so the guru reckons being vegetarian
makes you a joyful Karma person if
that's true then these kitchens must be
amongst the happiest places on
Earth the size of this place wow it's a
veggie hangout look at those vegetables
are they grown are they grown here a bit
of it that's incredible okay and here
the L chees would you like one I'd love
one please thank you how long you here
for um for a while for a while you're
baking the fundamental rules nobody ever
eats in the kitchen before the food is
being offered to everybody they never
eat you can't eat around food we're
always picking in kitchens no fancy a
cucumber no fine fancy Eli you gave me
it it got me into trouble we're not
allowed to eat in the kitchen how many
meals would you be cooking for today
about 7,000
7,000 7,000 vegetarian meals well that
breaks my heart
the 70 chefs are mostly unpaid
volunteers who work 7 Days on the Trot
feeding visitors to the ashram where's
the meat
section the meat is here this is the
meat so what is this section they're
making a special type of Chapa 7,000 in
for dinner tonight and look how calm it
is how come the kitchen's so calm cuz
they're not eating meat right because
this the Heaven's
kitchen Heaven's kitchen not Hell's
Kitchen I like that
the guru's disciples eat in a communial
dining hall in total silence men and
women sit in separate
lines tonight's menu is a raw salad of
red cabbage and sweet corn tomato
chutney with lentils and cottage
cheese it's not exactly Silver
Service eating in silence isn't easy for
someone like me fortunately I've made a
new friend you can even keep your feet
to the side that's side I'll try and
cross them
God on other way just stretch both your
legs out yes and sit like this on side
you mind if I do that this is called
grandmother's side grandmother's son
it's incredible I feel so bad that I
can't cross my
legs notice if you uh the kind of food
that you eat also makes the body loose
and flexible as well so you're saying if
I become a vegetarian my body will
become a lot more ve a lot more flexible
that
possibility I can't I can sit down but I
can't get to my food you can dis hold
your face certainly of course thank
you food is actually delicious what
amazes me is not just the level
Integrity but the volume of what they
cook for cuz it's done with such
Precision you ever ask for
more you want
together I never thought I'd say this
but that veggie meal has led me feeling
happy and
full w
[Music]
w where are we what's this
here what are these bedtime at 1
p.m. my God this place is extraordinary
honestly I mean that was quite uh that
was quite spooky in there I mean I know
they've got their guidelines and their
rules and regulations but Jesus Christ
Christ I have to say the food yeah total
respect yeah delicious and big eye
opener I mean I I thought it was going
to be a sort of you know a bit of a
boring Bland experience but it's
definitely not been boring and it
certainly isn't Bland that's for sure
right 1 minute to 10 [__]
off yesterday was a surprise but I've
not been turned into a veggie disciple
yet
we've not had breakfast yet the guru is
cooking his
speciality the popular Masala doser is a
pancake made with d and rice
batter that smells good smells very good
Smiley fermented
mhm that's the
potato it's an art to get the DOA right
because you have to ferment it to
exactly to right uh
proportions
that's delicious very crispy
mhm say this is a pepper Curry you just
try a little bit of it m the pepper
comes straight from our backyard really
it's organically grown thank you try
this and see it could be a little spicy
for
you yeah know I like that I've been one
over by the delicious food but I'm not
yet convinced by the guru's
reasoning for me a vegetable a vegetable
is as alive as a chicken or or a lamb or
whatever else you eat so wrong it is not
wrong are you saying that a carrot has
the same feelings as a chicken that's
not the point feelings does not mean
emotions they are sensitive to life
around them you understand but you've
killed it you've pulled it from the
ground you pulled it from the ground but
it's not dead if you plant it it will
grow you take such a high moral ground
in terms of no meat eating whatsoever
food is not a morality food is a
question of well-being so are you saying
that I would be happier for the second
half of my life without eating meat you
will be calmer at more more at ease but
I am calm I am I don't think the world
thinks so how about your calmness you
wouldn't know you don't have any
televisions
here let's agree to disagree yes Spud
potato love it thank you that a lovely
breakfast thank you it's taken a long
time but you heard it here first I'm
calling a ceasefire with vegetarians if
you're ever thinking of going vegetarian
then get to an ashram quickly because
that's the confirmation of how good it
can be but he is [__] nuts I think
he's gesticulating much less than
yesterday don't you notice that his body
movements a
little first of all I'm definitely more
chilled out there's no two ways about
that um yeah it has been uh an
experience the guru has one final
request Before We Say
Goodbye one day in a week if you eat
this kind of food know you would know
the difference one day a week and You'
think I'd notice a significant oh yes in
fact you will definitely notice that I
can't believe you're saying that H
because just before I left for India my
wife was suggesting that the children go
vegetarian see she knows one day a week
have you been talking to her behind my
back no no no no
no we'll start with one day good try and
see on the back of the experience here
yes I'm going to consider
it
my culinary Adventure in Southern India
has been a veggie road to Damascus but
I'm not eating meat yet South India's
fish is legendary I'm traveling from
tamilnadu into carala the fertile Green
State called God's own country damn so
nice it's calm here it has the best fish
and seafood in
India the small state provides 20% of
India
Supply I want to get my hands on some
this for me is going to be one of the
most exciting parts of the trip because
it's All About Seafood and fish and
Vibrance lightness excitement here we go
please
H oh brilliant excellent thank you
finally oh [__] air condition thank
you so welcome you sir to my goodone
country God's own country you know why
it's calling God's own country why
because we got lot of precious thing
it's got lots of lagoons Lake and the
most of the people here they do the
fishing we got a special fish over here
it's called caramine caramine yeah it's
called caramine you know it's very
delicious if you ask someone out of
India from this part uh are you missing
K they will cry for that you know when I
used to eat this car you know my tongue
will
do like that you know his English May
lack a little something but it turns out
my driver denesh really knows he's fish
it's a dream fish you know jewel in the
crown yeah so how'd you catch them uh
you know I got some friends over here
they are actually catching Curry mean
the backwaters are Carol's Labrinth of
lakes canals and rivers surrounded by
dense Tropical
Greenery the locals go crazy about
caramine the back waters are full of
them they're nicknamed pear spot because
of their Jewel likee
markins these are the fisherman T good
to see is good to
see we okay the you like you can
[Music]
whever caramina hand caugh using the
ancient V Valley method hey the
fisherman slapped the water to scare the
fish Who hide in the Lake's Muddy
Bottom nearby local domestic goddess and
food writer duressi John is going to
show me how to do justice to these
slippery
blighters W okay EXC very good how are
you I'm very fine how good to see you
now the secret behind it what we're
going to do take the scales off first
guts out yeah scales not the way you do
it with your SE bass you're going to
slice it off oh ready this is how you
take it off see it's coming it's exactly
the same way as the Japanese do oh
really yeah exactly the same way
normally we just scrape the scal yeah
yeah I know but you can't do this
because the taste of the scales will
remain on that it's not good think you
need a little more patience I think
garden and you know you don't you see
you have not sliced it see they're so
fiddly huh yes you're doing it yeah
excellent finally so your marks are
going up now actually we are supposed to
make the gashes on
this yes
yeah yeah that's fine that's fine what
was that another
C+ huh finally maybe I'll give you a
yeah I'm learning the Local's favorite
caramine poly chatau over here it's as
popular as a fish and chips garlic
in first we're making the Masala and
next Ginger Ginger yes yeah I don't need
the whole thing should I start for you
yeah yeah sure please than you now we'll
add the charlot shots in yeah can't
believe we cooking this on a boat and
what are we doing with this are we
putting this inside the fish yeah yeah
we're going to put it around the fish
and stuff it inside the St right I think
we'll put the tomatoes tomatoes in
already yeah wow I think chili powder
chili powder in yes and now we need to
put the vinegar so the vinegar yeah toy
vinegar and now we are going to make the
parcels right of the fish does that stop
the fish from sticking yes I think we
just need to put some here this is the
delightful Twist on the French technique
on papat but instead of steaming the
fish inside a paper bag we're using a
banana leaf and now I'm going to fold it
so you wrap it quite tight yeah we wrap
it rather
tight and how long will they take to
cook uh about 15 to 20 minutes
maximum this banana parcel keeps all the
moisture and flavor locked in so you're
searing it in
[Music]
yeah
that looks fantastic it's to slide the
fish over the bone look at
that wow how does it
taste that's delicious creamy delicious
and I thought it was going to taste
slightly of mud of silt but no it's
fresh it's vibrant it's very dense
B them into ad DOA so but a little bit
sweeter incredibly
delicate thank you wow very
[Music]
good that fish was delicious but this
Carnival is still hanging after some
meat so the next day I've arranged for a
boy own
adventure I've heard that carola has a
reputation for a very hot but delicious
chili beef dish it's eating together
with an infamously strong
Tipple and waiting for a local Chef AIT
who's going to take me
drinking AIT is an expert um in totty
which is a local drink here now you
drink that with the most amazing chili
beef so if there's one guy that can show
me the proper way on how to do it what
it tastes like it's going to be
him hey Garden a how are you excellent
hop in hop in let's go good to see you
well likewise good to see you
too here we go thank you oh [__] hold on
excellent
toddy is the fermented sap of the
coconut palm it's strong stuff up to 35%
proof it's collected in pots attached
high up in the
tree Chef AIT is taking me to where
toddy is produced we're going to show
you how the toddy tapping is done toy
tapping yeah you see see the pot over
there like a big bowl yeah that that's
where the Tod is being collected so how
do you get that down twice a day because
you're not exactly the slimmest and I'm
not exactly the sort of you know fittest
you know what I've I've arranged for a
gentleman his name is Mr Babu Babu yeah
he does it for a living what a
professional he's a professional toddy
Tapper there are more than 30,000
registered toddy tappers in Kerala he's
going to show you how how it's been done
and I want you to do it after him Mr
Baboo how are
you look he's not saying anything that
means he's either pissed as a fart or
he's got his tongue cut out he's like a
he's like a flexible piece of OCA
there's not anything on him look my
thighs are fatter than him look at that
there so what's the secret of climbing
what is it it appears that having a
stiff one before climbing is recommended
oh Jesus
Offa
okay wow see his hands how is mov but
look at him Baboo uses a rag wrapped on
his feet to give him leverage to climb
he's like a little
feret huh Jesus watch
out so now he's draining the he do the
the sap into his
bowl three times a day no wonder he's so
fit H well done Little T thank you so is
toddy as formidable a Tipple as I've
been
told
[__] it's nice but you know it's like
unrefined vinegar H Jesus no wonder like
no wonder he climbs like a squirrel
could you hold that for me please socks
and shoes
off come on give me the give me no no wa
S I need the other piece as well pissing
around you fat bastard you fat bastard
you at all the pies right here we
[Laughter]
go well least [__] help him then hold
on look him he's like a wishbone push
him up a [__] tree help him that's
[__] come on one more I I I need I
need to do it without don't Chen don't
be
chcken my first step is promising oh
[__] I push you
up you way too
much oh come on my days of humping a
[__] coconut tree I've got to stop I
tell you what they make it look so easy
price bloody harder I mean really hard
I'm going leave it to the experts I hate
failing you little [__] making me look
like a TW
H I liked you when I first arrived you
know that I thought you were cool yes
66y old putting my tars and Antics
behind me I'm hoping for some meat at
last carola's famous hot chili beef at a
totty
shop these shops are Cara's version of
the working man's Boozer there are over
5,000 of them and a busy shop can sell
over 1,000 lers of tody a day this is
where we get the chili beef from oh yes
yeah I'm dying to taste some beef good
evening hello hello I'm dying to taste
the beef I need meat
okay lovely this is a local Rustic
Kitchen that you rustic or Rusty Rustic
Kitchen that you get in these shops this
gentlemen is Sun Sun sir
please the chili beef served in toddy
shops is famously hot to encourage
customers to drink more booze you really
need to have a St strong stomach to eat
on this places strong stomach yeah it's
like the perfect way to say goodbye yeah
eat drink be merried get pissed and get
buried at the same time he's putting an
onion coconut ginger garlic and green
chili okay nice and every tody shop has
a different style different St of making
okay and how popular is this one there
are people who come here 7 days a
week unusually for Southern India but
luckily for me 90% of carolans are
carnivores tast it like yeah of course
I'm going to taste it I've seen some
Kitchen Nightmares in my time but you
need to be brave or stupid to eat in
this
joint
[Music]
taste okay
okay super
super no the dir super hot Jesus Christ
almighty my mouth is on fire H where's
the T does have to be that
hot he say it's pure coconut
dirty
it's excellent I love it
perfect Jesus
Christ a it a it oh yeah what are you
trying to do kill
me doesn't that burn you you enjoy the
chili beef twice once once when you eat
it and once when you let it go my bottom
wouldn't stand that
that it's going to come through my
[__] in seconds and I got no toilet
paper and I'm not doing it again on a
Banana Leaf no
chance but my next destination will make
all that seem like Child's Play I've
arranged for an Excursion from my
culinary
Voyage I've heard that in Northern
kerola the farmers love a sport called
Cula which only happens in flooded Patty
Fields this place is heaving with
thousands of punters but there's
something very odd about this race
course what are they what is that sir
it's like a
[Music]
oh my God this is a load of
Bullocks this lot have got balls and
they know how to race
them holy
[Applause]
[__] dangerous [__] mad
mad I've been to motorbike Grand Prix
Formula 1 grand prix horse racing point
to point but this beats everything
they've asked me to hand out the prizes
so
congratulations the winning jockeys are
treated like Formula 1 Champions and can
win around 600 Quid a
race would you like to give it a shot i'
like to give it a go yeah is he crazy
yeah of course I'd love to give it a go
yes
[Music]
please
[Applause]
hold hold on hold on hold on they're
going to pull it for you I'm going to
start off slowly learning to balance
without a thrashing bull
[Applause]
around [__] how can your ass have a tip
without a bll in front of you oh f
okay bring the balls yes
okay all the
best no no no
don't
we
I'm down but by no means out I've been
in fast cars fast bikes even 12 mph in a
jet but
[Applause]
this F me what a ride on the back of two
balls India's been the maximum country
for me maximum surprise maximum people
and maximum
flavor I'm returning from Kerala to the
place called India's maximum City Mumbai
where my adventure reaches its
climax
I've heard that some of India's best
cooking happens not in top restaurants
or hotels but on the streets 26% of
Indians live in
poverty I can't leave India without
discovering how the poor eat so well on
so little so we're just entering dravi
and it's the largest slum in Asia houses
over a million people Slum Dog
Millionaire was filmed on the streets of
the sprawling durvi slum IL legally
built durvi is the most densely
populated neighborhood in the
world this may seem an unlikely spot to
find a culinary genius but today I'm
going to have an apprenticeship under a
Ghetto Superstar Chef his name is Manny
sber Manny is his nickname he's got a
big do on tonight he's quite good at the
most amazing Samba samb's like a like a
sort of savory sort of hot Minon sou so
today I'm going to be shown how to make
one
properly Dar is a Curry House favorite
of mine and sber is a version of it a
cheap staple dish made with lentils and
veg Manny's asked me to help him make
his famous sber for a big birthday party
in the
slum s money yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah fine sir how are you fine sir good
to see you good you money SAR money Su
money Su M yes sir okay good now we have
a big dinner
tonight dinner small dinner about 100 oh
Jesus where's the
kitchen this is kitchen the kitchen is
the kitchen this is the kitchen yes sir
so we are seriously cooking on the
street
yeah even though his kitchen is
rudimentary Manny is a stickler for
discipline and expects his chefs to wear
the
uniform Manny doesn't care who I am to
him I'm just a lowly Comm Chef in a
Street Kitchen and good sber is a labor
intensive
dish
first I'm going to make the Masala or
spice mix for the
sber ah good good good Manny has his own
secret blend of spices for the Masala
which gives the sber its unique
flavor they've started toasting off the
fenig Greek seeds the yellow split peas
coriander Curry leaves and then the
chilies and then they're going to grind
it so we got this fresh fragrant Masala
base from
sber ah yeah yeah got it got it it's
amazing to think we're in the place
where they film th up millionaire darari
coconut in good good good good so that's
going to sweeten the Masala coconut in
southern Indian Cuisine is Paramount
it's like uh potatoes back in the UK
they they play that much
importance now we going to cook the
lentils yep okay good now we begin
making the sber
itself that's take this out yeah lentils
in so much effort and Care going into
cooking this food is almost like it's a
fine dining aspect but it's not it's a
vegetarian dish in the middle of a slum
love it love it love it love it now it's
hot H Manny yes Z now it's very
hot even though Manny is a successful
Chef he still lives in a makeshift two
roomed
house how many you got to look after in
the family how big is the family 12
people in this family 12 that's a large
family and is everybody living here yes
all of them live in the same house that
he keep on working till he can move I
like that attitude very Happ happy with
my shopping happy happy
[Music]
onion it's over 30° and we're now going
up a gear to finish the
sber Jesus Christ I tell you what next
time I want to run a marathon I'm going
to come back to Mumbai and work in the
slum for a day perfect training this
kitchen is like padly
circus it's getting busy now Y is it tea
time traffic yeah
[__] now we're going to do the Masala
paste this is putting my spicy sber
Masala in is crucial to give this dish a
distinctly deep flavor what up what up
finally we add the
lentils it smells absolutely delicious
this just becomes so perfumed and
fragrant thank
you that is
delicious look he knows isn't he he
knows this for 10p
portion there's not a moment to breathe
the birthday guests have
arrived come on and Manny and I are
serving my name is Gordon Gordon Gordon
Gordon that's right thank you so
two
one two so what do the guests
think very great for a foreigner to come
and prepare Indian food very ni
something very very great amazing golden
Ramsey s r is very good very good yummy
we hope you to be here again I'd love to
come back yeah come back very delicious
and amazing that fora prepared such a
delicious dinner for us ladies best
wishes good
night well successful
thank you I thought it was going to be
good but I didn't think it was going to
be that
spectacular sir God BL this is my
friends Mar you we are friends till we
die exactly that exactly thank you H
it's been an absolute pleasure pleasure
thank you Manny Slum Dog sber is the
essence of Great Southern Indian cookery
it tastes amazing and costs next to
nothing been here today was uh it's
quite nerving then when you get out of
the car and you start melting in to the
street in a way that you you work hard
to be accepted by them the minute they
see that they connect with you straight
away because they are a nation that are
grafters and S Manny well yeah I mean
he's a yeah a passionate exciting
50-year-old Chef that you know knows his
[__] big
[Music]
time
when I began my Indian Adventure I
didn't know how to cook curry but now I
want to challenge myself have I learned
enough to compete at the highest
level there is a major dinner happening
in Mumbai tonight with the country's
best
chef it's at the Taj Mahal hotel and
I've got into the kitchen to cook the
main
course the Taj Hotel is the Chic lamb
Mark building of Mumbai which tragically
is why it was the target of a vicious
terrorist outrage just over a year ago
31 guests and staff were
murdered I can't think of a more fitting
place to come back and have my final
dinner in this unique building can't
wait to meet the chef I know he lost
several members of his team throughout
those terrorist attacks and yeah quite
nervous really I just want to put my
head down and
graft thank
you Herman oberoy executive chef of the
Taj is India's most influential Chef
he's cooked for everyone from Prince
Charles to Bill
Clinton there are 25 High Society guests
coming tonight and for Chef ooy
everything has to be
perfect you should be giving only the
best if you are a good Chef you should
be giving the best there's no place for
second best
today Chef heroy doesn't care that I'm
new to Indian Cuisine he's trusting me
to deliver the goods and I want to cook
a dish that does Justice to my culinary
adventures In
India I've decided on an ambitious fish
dish using the delicious caramine I
discovered in
carola I didn't realize I thought it
3:00 it's 4:00 so think they're arriving
in 3 hours time and I've got [__] all
done we're going to make a very simple
fish stop okay really really simple the
legend has arrived how are you sir Hi
how are you you've been in meetings all
day how are you very well thank you very
happy to be here I'm here to steal as
many recipes as possible all
right this is no competition but when
you get two big igos in one kitchen
there's bound to be a bit of
rivalry Chef heroy is making a crap
starter and he's keeping a Keen Eye on
what I'm
doing so coriander stares and vanilla
yeah first I'm cooking a fish stock for
a vanilla sauce he's making the Indian
flavors in the typical Western way he's
making a St he's making the fum he's a
good chef and he knows what he's doing I
have a radical idea to fill it the Bony
caramine and cook it three ways slightly
kamakazi but hey so the idea for the
first one is lining them with a
freshwater prw and mousse and then a
really delicious fish top the light one
with vanilla and the coriander and the
second one would
be playing to the strengths in Mumbai
over a red curry and then the third one
I'm going try and do a nice lights
crispy batter marinade the fish first a
little bit of
turmeric there's a lot riding on this
dinner the tar has been restored to its
former glory it was destroyed in the
attack but the hotel bravely reopened
just a month
afterwards not me are we in the
[__] in my attempt to impress Chef oboy
I think I may have bitten off more than
I can chew here I'm struggling with my
fish
batter the batter is not crispy enough
fres is not hot enough the batter's too
light so it's going to be soft as [__]
red curry I want this to become really
nice and sort of uh authentic lots of
fresh tomatoes lots of chili lots of
garlic and then with the the end fill it
I'm going to be trying and why the [__]
I decideed to cook this three ways I
don't know slap it through the batter
fry it and serve it with the
okra who turned the [__] fire off
that's all I need
I hope he's getting ready it's almost
like
5:00 probably he should have started a
little earlier I'm sure two hours and
he's got only fish dish and fish doesn't
take time I suppose all the excitement
all the anxiety all the experience it's
going to be exploding three ways onto
one plate so if I go out I want to go
out on a high where we're here with one
of the best chefs in the country and I'm
going to match him I'm not here here to
match him I'm here to show him what I've
learned that's the
secret at this dinner are the creme de
La Creme of Mumbai
Society Bollywood
actors soal
lights and the Maharaja of
udor as service looms the pressure's
getting to me are we going straight off
the crab you're after the crab after the
crab yeah let me know when you sent all
the crab thank you sir excellent don't
drop me in the [__] now please huh come
on I'm not as fast as you I'm getting
old oh than you
don't after a last minute scramble my
complex caramine dish has finally come
together I use an old trick to sort out
my soggy
batter that's much better nice and
crispy now they needed a Bott of beer in
there good old English Style
over in terms of um three individual
tastes drawing on carola drawing on
Mumbai and drawing a little bit of
English there with a beer batter so far
so good that's one put together let's
see how the we get on with 25 portions
it's going to be about uh 10 more
minutes when they will sit down okay 10
more minutes okay
great okay here we go thing
[Music]
go
just enough time to check up on Chef
heroy for a change but just how many
chefs has he got helping
[Music]
him no no I'm fine with my two guys 22
and I've got two it's great yeah it's
nice there's more chefs than there our
customers
[Music]
lovely 24 chefs cooking for 21 customers
so 1 2 3 yeah we got to come out on top
yes never be intimidated by the
opposition at the last minute I'm
steaming the caramine to go with my
vanilla
sauce just going to be very careful
cooking the fish timing has got to be
absolutely crucial the fish is done
three ways tempora goes in at the last
minute and make sure we sting these very
gently seven put eight in there quick
and then tilt the pant okay off you
go
[__] man as soon as this delicate fish
is ready it must go straight out lift
the plate up and put it in his hand CO's
on please I get the feeling Chef heroy
enjoying this gently gently gently
gently
go no two plates maximum thank you three
[__] times and keep the plates
straight
pleas my Great Escape Adventure is it's
all on this one
[Music]
dish I've never wanted a recipe to
succeed as much as this
[Music]
one you know you put your balls on the
line you pick up on what they're doing
and you learn quickly then you want to
compete with
them and so should I kept it simple and
wrapped it in a banana leaf and Tak an
easy route no that's not me
oh this is very very good it's very
typical of Kerala and I think it's
fabulous but fry very British I like
that I've got the British in with that I
loved it very subtle
but it certainly present the South
Indian flavor I like what I'm eating
whatever it is it is wonderful I'm old
and deaf
speaker I thought that for a footballer
he cooks
beautifully I think it's a good effort
but is my color Mentor rash me impressed
what is amazing is that he's managed to
distill the flavors of South India and
yet put in his own typical Gordon ramse
twist wow what a beautiful
room ladies gentl excellent good to see
you um first of all thank you so much
for kind I couldn't think of a more
fitting place to confirm how exquisite
your Cuisine is so a big thank you to
Chef the team has been amazing um
congratulations a phenomenal hotel and
um it's back as number one
brilliant the time's come for me to say
goodbye to a country I've fallen in love
with being here for this length of time
has really helped to not just renew my
passion with Indian food but it's made
me it's made me think more because it
has an amazing effect not just the the
food and ingredients but the
people it's been a hot hectic hell of a
ride through this addictive
country hello hello hello
hello
[Music]
shck cuz this the Heaven's
kitchen okay right who's pissed him
off don't [__] shoot Gordon come back
come back we need you we need to do the
ditch you just need a video back a
little
[Music]
more she's off a
trolley dangerous [__] mad
[Music]
mad that's [__]
delicious the experience has been
[__] amazing learning again that's
been the huge excitement am I going to
do anything differently when I get back
home yeah bloody right I will I won't
phone up for a takeaway I'll make it
thank you
excellent let's
go Mumbai airport please does this thing
go any
faster